で  第1の講義はこのモラルとモラリストの裏ということで
で で 一応疑問にするのは
なんで世の中で道徳というものがあって
また崇高道徳というものもあるんでしょうか
その裏なんですね はい
今日はそのテーマで喋ります
で いきなり難しいことを言いますけど
この Absolute and Conditionality という
で なかなか日本語が見つからない
なかったので そのまま英語で書いてしまったんですけど
Absolute というのはこの哲学で使う言葉で
この絶対的な存在を示すために使う言葉なんですね Conditional
というのは この条件によって現れるものっていう
あの絶対的ではない 一時的
だから Absolute というものの反対なんです
これ哲学の世界では まあよくこの Absolute という絶対的な何かあるんだぞという考え方っていうのはすごい強いんです
人間何も知らなくても
そう思ってるんですね
なんか自分を支配してるとか
何か自分たる何かあるんだぞと
で 何も知識のない ただ一般の人々の思っていることが
ものすごい複雑に哲学的な物事を考える人は同じことを言うんです
だから まあどうったことないんじゃないかなと思いますけど
それで あのもう一つ あのちょっと哲学的な単語がございまして
この Relative という Relative
というのは相対的ということで
何かに何かに対照して比較してみると
もう何か言えるという
それも一応 Conditional という条件付きということの中に入るんです
だから Conditional の一部なんです Relative
というのは 相対論も Conditional の説明でいえば
例えば今日は寒いでしょうかというと
寒くないと 結構過ごしやすい天気ですね
でもこれは Conditional 条件付きなんです
そういう風にちょっと空気が変わって
コンディションが変わったんだから
今日は過ごしやすいんですけど
明日は分かったものでないんですね
明後日は分かったものじゃないんですね
で ずっと続くわけじゃないんです
で 今日はお元気ですか？と
そうだったら まあ一生大丈夫だということは言えませんね
今日だけは元気ですと
明日はわからないんですよ
なぜかというと 私たちは今日は元気ですよと
この元気ということが
条件によって成り立っているものなんですね
条件崩れちゃうとすぐ元気っていうことはなくなっちゃうんです
それが Conditional という説明
でも Relative というのはものすごい単純で
この相対的 相対論っていうのはね
まあ例えばあれってよく長いでしょうという場合は
頭の中で何かと比較 何かと比較して短いものに比較してるんですよ
皆さんはこの講義 今日聞いてるこの建物
ビルっていうのは結構高層
何ビルですかね 高層ビルですよ
言うと 他のビルと比べてこれが高層ビルというんです
でないと高層っていう言葉を使えないんです
そこで 善悪 良い悪い 長い短いというか
あらゆる概念は全てそういう相対的で
これにガラスというのも相対的な考え方なんですね
他と比較して他と違いますから
ガラスという名前を付けているんです
そういう感じで 世の中は全部相対的で
全て相対的なんですね
何かに比較しないと 自分自身だけでは生きていられないんです
例えば 短いという概念がなければ
長いというものは成り立たない
単語も消えちゃうんです
例えば 世の中で悪があるんだぞと言っちゃうと
必ず善があって悪があるっていうことなんです
だから一つ単語を使っちゃうと
もう一つついてくるんです
それはよく気をつけないとね
みんな我々はそれを無視するんだから
世の中の哲学も宗教も全部もうむちゃくちゃになってるんです
役に立たなくなってるんですよ
単語 概念 またあるものは
いつでも何か引っ張ってくるんです
あの人いい人ですよ その人のことを考えてそう言うんだけど
本当にそうじゃないんです
誰かと比べているんです
悪い人間と ですから あの人いい人ですよっていうことは absolute ではないんです
絶対的でないんです もし別な人と比べてみたところで
ものすごい立派な人と比べてみると
やっぱりあの人は大したことはないんだということになっちゃうんです
だから今我々が考えているものっていうのは
結局何に比較しているのかっていうぐらいのことで
そんなどうってことないんですよ
別なものに比較すると
今の考え方は全部なくなっちゃうんです
それわかると随分とすごく難しいことなんですけど
大変な素晴らしいことになるんですよ
例えば私なんか 世の中っていうのは本当にくだらないと思ってるんだよと言う場合は
自分が自分の考え方に随分しがみついてるでしょうね
私がそう思ってるんだから
あんた方何言うでしょうかと
人と当たったりまでする
でもあんなのは相対的で
私が何かに比較してるだけなんですよ
それで比較した対象 別なものに比較しちゃうと
世の中っていうのはもうどうにもならない
くだらんといった考え方が消えてしまうんです
だから我々の生き方 考え方
好き嫌い 何でも一時的で相対的で
ちょっとしたことでも飛んでしまっちゃうんです
だから そんなにも粘り強くしがみついて
自我を張って生きる必要はないんですよ
何一つも だいたいみんな私は私なりにしっかり生きてきたんだぞという場合は
えらい高慢でしょ 見え張ってるんです
そうは思わないんでしょうと言っちゃうと
もうかなり攻撃されますよ
だから そういう考え方についてしがみつく必要ないんですよ
もし自分が誰かに比較している
自分の家の誰が誰かに
あるいは知り合いの誰か誰かに
もし外外他のいろんな人々と比較してみると
なんだ 私はだらしなかった
あの人と比べると あのしっかりした生き方と比べるということで
自分のあの考え方は消えてしまうんですよ
好き嫌いも同じなんですよ
この食べ物は私はものすごく大好物ですよと
これはもう生まれつきでしようがないんだよ
思ったってあんまり当てにならないんですよ
もしその人が別な食べ物に出会ったところで
それが好物になっちゃうと
これがもう 飛んでしまうんです
人間の人生すべて そういう風にレラティブという立場で考えるのは仏教の考え方なんです
それだけで心は穏やかになって
誰とも戦わない立派な人間になるんだよ
それははっきり理解すれば
それこそ悟りの境地なんです
頭の中で何の概念もなくなくなっちゃうんです
だって一切の概念は相対的だからね
概念を持たせると そこで執着が生まれる
日本って美しい国だなと思ったら
それ概念ですよ 同時に執着が生まれるんですよ
外国っていうのはすごい不安定で怖いんだなと
それは概念ですよ そうすると外国に対しても執着が生まれるんです
それってどういう執着ですかね
怖くてたまらんということは
あれも執着ですよ 嫌がるんだからね
心から離れませんだからね
だから執着といえば好きだけじゃないんです
嫌いも執着なんです だって
現に皆様は嫌いな人のことを全然忘れ忘れられないでしょうに
好きな人のことを忘れちゃっても
嫌な人のことだけは忘れられないでしょうに
やっぱり根張り強く執着しているんです
だから 概念というのは相対的で
ちょっとしたことで潰れてしまう
別な概念になってしまう
そんなものを理解すると
結構心は穏やかになる
悟りの境地に近寄る 一切概念を落としたところで
もう相対レベルがもう消えちゃって
それが悟りというんですね
ブッダの教えでは だからブッダの教えがあまりわかりやすくて
本当に申し訳ないんですけど
他の宗教の教えだったら随分難しくてかっこいいしね
そこで道徳の話をしゃべろうと思って
なんでこんなにもとてつもない哲学的なことを言うのかとね
まあそのうちわかるでしょうが
で じゃあ次にあの赤い文字で書いているところはね
仏教は ABSOLUTE ということは否定する
絶対的変わらないということはもう徹底的に否定する
ありえないんだ だって ABSOLUTE 絶対的なものがあるんだということさえも相対的でしょ
常に壊れてしまう我々に比較して
ABSOLUTE があると思うだけ
それも頭のからくりなんですよ
で 対照したものと全く正反対のことは見つけてもないのにあると思っちゃう
例えば長いといえば短いのものを知ってるでしょうね
それは大丈夫です 問題はありません
あの方は美人ですよと言っちゃうと
もう何か頭の中で自分知ってる美人でない人のこと
まあほとんど自分のことなんですけど
それ言わないだけのことで自分と比較しているんですよ
女性の場合は まあ男性の場合は自分の好みと比較しているんです
だから気をつけてください
男に言われたらあんたすごい綺麗ですよと言うと
やばいんです もう単純ですよ
女性があの方綺麗ですよと言ったら
必ず自分に比較しているんです
言わないですよ それ決して
男性の場合は まあああいうことで
そういう風にまあ 美人ですよとか言ったところで
綺麗ですよと言ったところで
私たちは具体的にそうでないものが頭の中にあるんですよ
今日の味噌汁はまずいんだよと言うと
もしかすると昨日の味噌汁に比較しているんです
その場合は具体的なんです
問題はありません しかし
自分が付き合ってるもうもう人々の間でろくな人間はいない
それってそれで時々  うちの連中よりはもしかすると世の中で立派な人がいるでしょう
立派人に会えば楽しいでしょうと思っちゃうんです
私は今苦しんでいるのは
自分の仲間 うち うちの連中やら付き合い
知り合いのみんなもろくでもない人間だから
わがまま放題で だから苦しんでいるんだと
もしわがままないのない
思いやりのある立派な人と付き合えば穏やかでしょうと思うだけ
会ったことはまだないんです
そんな人はいるかないかもわからないんです
ただ単に自分の今経験している経験から相対的に次の概念を作るんです
だから相対論だから必ずあるんですよ
次の概念が 相対的だから思考はあるんだからといって
そのものが実際するってのはまた別なんです
それ気をつけてほしいです
だからこの ABSOLUTE ということは
絶対的な何かあるんだということは
人間が絶対的でない世の中を自分を見て
それなりにああ こんな嫌な状態ではなくて
もっとすごいものがあるんじゃないかなというふうに思っちゃう
しかしブッダはそれはありえないんだと
まったくありえないんだと断言するんです
存在は存在自体は相対的である
だからいろんな経典でもものすごく延々と言ってるんですが
この短い引用っていうのはなかなか出しにくいんですよ
これ大変な問題だから
お釈迦様は結構長く伸ばして喋るんです
すごい詳しく 例えば物質というものが過去のものであろうか
今ここにある物質であろうか
それから現れを現れようとする物質であろうか
全てが作られたもので
相対的であると そういうふうに一つ一つのあなたの考え方は
今の考え方であろうか
過去の考え方であろうか
これから人間が考える考え方であろうか
それで相対的である そういうふうな話ですから
ちょっとこれっていう意味は出しにくい
でもしかし お釈迦様が使っている言葉はいくつかたくさんあります
相対的ということを示すために
というか コンディショナルと相対的とは一部だから
コンディショナルといえば無条件です
条件付きということね
コンディショナルであるというために作った言葉
使った言葉がございまして
カタン作られたもの サンカラとも言うんですね
現象であると全て作られたものである
サンカタンというのはまたおなじみで
パティッチサムッパンナンっていうのは言葉単語なんです
原因によって現れるものである
因縁によって現れるんであって
因縁が崩れちゃうとすべて崩れる
最近の例なんですよ 我々は大きな建物を作ったり
線路を作ったり 道路を作ったり
あるのはもう地面 地盤が硬いというコンディションでしょ？条件でしょ
だから地盤が硬いんだから
道路は成り立つ 線路も成り立つ
そこで地盤が新潟のようにちょっと崩れたらどうなるんですかというと
全部崩れちゃうんです
だから条件付きなんです
このパティッチサムッパンナンというのは
英語の単語で言えばコンディショナルということなんです
条件付きということで
サムデダンマンというのは現れるものであるということは
条件によって現れたものだから消えるんだよと
だからカエダンマン消えるものであると
ワエダンマンなくなるものであると
だからすべてそんなものであるというのはブッダの考え方なんです
絶対的なものはなし これは道徳の基本になる考え方ですから
忘れないでほしい ずっと覚えてほしいんですけど
どうしましょうかね この尺度でこれから講演が進んでいきますけどね
それから道徳の意味 ちょっと考えてみましょう
定義 あまりこれは定義じゃないんです
いい加減です 普通は私はずっと定義して喋りますが
道徳ですから ちょっといい加減な意味だけにしたんです
まあ不道徳というのはまあ行ってはならないと
行為を示すんですね それは分かりやすいですね
不道徳では行ってはならないこと
やってはいけないこと
道徳と言えば行うことをのさばらしい行為ですね
それはもう意味ですね
なんでみんな知ってる分かりやすいことを言うのかというと
当たり前だとちょっとしない方がいいんです
覚えた方がいいんです
以上の 2つは普通の日常生活に関わる行為を除くものだと思われる
これただの意見だから
皆様は違う意見を持ってるかもしれません
例えば私はご飯食べた
今日は これは道徳ですか？不道徳ですかね
今日そう考えれば 今日歯も磨いました
磨きましたと あれって道徳でなきゃ非道徳
どちらでもないでしょう
ですから 道徳と不道徳という場合は
日常生活の行為は除くことじゃないかなと
なぜなら 日常的な行為は必要なものなのに
それだけでは道徳的だと言われないからです
日常生活の行為っていうのは必要ですよ
だから言われなくてもやってますよ
みんなお腹が空いたら
言われなくてもご飯食べる
眠くなったら言われなくても寝る
寒くなったら言われなくても体を暖かくする
だからそれしなさい あれしなさいって言う必要はないんです
どうせやるんです だから
その理由で日常生活の行為は道徳論には入れないということにする
では 道徳論に入らない行為もあるようですね
そういう結論でそこに行きます
日常生活 仏教の話が進んだところで
そういう概念ちょっと変えます
あの後で今日ではないんです
日常生活の行為よりプラスアルファの行為は道徳ですね
言わなくてもやるやるものではなくて
もうちょっと言わなきゃやらない
あるいは自分でちょっと踏ん張らないとできないこと
わかりやすい例で言えば
まあどこかにね まあ公園を掃除に行くんだと
綺麗にしようと やっぱり頼まなきゃいけないでしょ
何かグループを組んで
まあもう日曜日 今度の日曜日9時から11時までやりましょうとかね
あとはボランティアをするとかね
えーと寄付をするとか
もう何て言いますか あの赤い羽寄付とずっと頼んでいるんだから
まあ募金してくださいと
それであげたりはする
でないと忘れちゃうんですね
1年に一回 その日にちになってくると
日本国全部みんな募金活動をやっているで思い出しちゃって
何か募金する寄付するんですからね
だからそういう風にこのプラスアルファの行為なんですね
日常生活の行為の妨げになる行為は非道徳になるのです
それで非道徳っていうのは
日常生活を妨げる 例えば自分の家に空き巣に入られちゃうと
自分の日常生活はむちゃくちゃでしょ
それは非道徳なんです
分かりやすいんです 日常生活を邪魔邪魔するもの
プラスアルファだったらマイナスアルファでしょうかね
まあそれはちょっと論理的に合わないんだから書かなかったんですけど
しかし 宗教 政治 制度 社会
家族などに決める行為はあります
だから今 私の定義は日常生活ということ定義に基本にしたんですけど
日常生活よりはプラスアルファの行為は道徳で
日常生活は妨げるものが非道徳で不道徳でいったのに
宗教家が あるいは政治制度があらゆる国々にある
それから我々生きてる社会
社会 一人一人がいろんな社会に生活して
みんな同じ社会にいるわけじゃないんです
それから自分の家族とかね
そちらにも作るんですよ
道徳と非道徳 不道徳は
それって本当に日常生活に関係あるかないかっていうのはちょっとわからないです
アメリカが一人の人間が戦争するそうと決めたら
もうアメリカ人が戦争を賛成することが道徳的で愛国主義で立派なんです
戦争に反対するのはとんでもない悪人なんですね
それで道徳決めちゃったんですよ
そうやって一人の人間にも
例えばある家庭で父親がこれこれやってはならないとかね
例えばある父親が自分の娘さんに
もう八時半までに家に入らなきゃダメやと
厳しく決める ある家庭で
まあもうもう勝手に遊んだって日本が大丈夫だからね
好きな時で我々は寝ますよと
いう風に もうそこら辺は道徳設定してない場合もあります
あるいは女はもう八時半までに来なくちゃいかんですけど
男の子は息子はもう十時半までやと
門限はと で 決めることもあるし
あるいは別な場合は男ならもうずっと来なくたってもいいんだと
遊びに行ってというふうに言う父親もいるかもしれませんよ
そういう それが日常生活に何の関係あるのかということは
ちょっとわかりにくいんですね
それぞれ自分の家ではバランドの服しか買わないんだぞとかね
あるいは自分の家では絶対そんなものは買わないと
夫婦で決めたりする 時々もうゲームはやらせないと
道徳決めちゃうと あのうち自分のうちの子供がもしゲームやったならば
これは道徳を犯してるんですよ
そういう風に このそれぞれの個人が
社会がもう勝手に決めたものもあります
それが前の定義で関係ないんですね
これは必ずしも日常生活に関わるものであるかというと
そうじゃないものもいっぱいあります
例えば 国 国の政府が作る法律っていうのは
そんなにも日常生活に関わるのかと
いろんなこと決めてますよ
日本は日本なりにいろんなもうどうでもいいことをいっぱい決めているし
で 他の国ももうどうでもいいことを
もうそれも勝手に決めてるんですね
例えばサウジアラビアだったら
女は投票してはいけないとかね
仕事をしてはいけないとか
そういう風な そのその国によっても決めるものがあるんです
宗教は明確にね 例えばラマダンと
今ラマダンですけどね
もう朝 昼の光が見えた時から昼の光が消えるまで
星一つ見える時まで食べない
何も それが 1ヶ月間だけなんです
夜はものすごいむちゃくちゃ食べる
それでラマダンの月終わったら
結構みんな体重が増えてる
それは我々行ったら宗教批判であって殺される恐れもありますけど
私はそういう人々の新聞記事やら読んで行ってるんです
だから宗教もそういういろんなね
別に日常生活にはそんなに関係ないにも関わらず
もう 1 日 5 回お祈りしなさいとかね
イスラム教の場合は キリスト教の場合は必ず日曜日
あの 神に祈りしなさいとかね
食べる前にちゃんと神に感謝しなさいとかね
感謝しなくても食べられますけどね
それによって何か日常生活なんとかなるってことはないと思いますけど
それは必ずしも上の定義に合うのではないのです
だから この 3番目と 4番目に書いたものは
上の 2つの上書いた定義にははめない
合わない しかし そういう道徳は世の中であるということは知ってほしいんです
守りなさいという意味じゃないんです
どちらにしたっても それは私の管轄ではありません
はい 次に行きます それで道徳の弱み
まずやりたくはないでしょう
で ここからちょっと正直にならないと
ちょっと話がわからなくなります
見栄張っちゃうと 道徳っていうのは正直なところやりたくないでしょうに
例えば毎日のようにいろんな組織から寄付してください
寄付してください 自分の家に訪ねてくると気分がいいんですかね
人を助けることはいいことでしょう
それで毎日誰かが来るんだったら
結構うんざりするでしょうね
例えば嘘をつくついてはいけないっていうのはね
まあ言うてことは言うんだけど
どうですか 皆様の正直なところは
何の躊躇もなく もう嘘ばっかりずっと
もう 1時間喋っちゃうと
もう 55 分ぐらい嘘ばっかり言ってるんだからね
それが道徳の弱みなんですよ
やりたくないんだから
やる人っていうのはほとんどないっていうのは事実なんです
次には この褒美があるならやる気になる
時々すごいケチな人もいて
このからくりあるんですよ
何かケチですけど 金がある
そこであなたはこれを言ってれば
この名誉市民にしてあげるぞとかね
国賓として 例えば外国の場合はね
迎えて あの 何か褒賞状あげますよとかね
言うとすごいケチで 溜まったお金なんですけど
どんと出しちゃうんです
あの ご褒美ありますから
あるいはもうこういうことをしたら天国に行けますよとか
なんとか宗教でいうと
そのご褒美を狙って道徳っていうのは守る気になるんですね
で 非道徳は普通はやりたいと思う行為ですよ
これで非道徳っていうのは
もうやりたくてやりたくてたまらんですね
脅し 罰などの制度があればやめる
本当は非道徳不道徳的なことをやりたいんですよ
でも脅しがあるわ 罰があるわ
ただでは済まないんですよ
だからやらないだけで
銀行強盗でも面白いんですけど
大金も手に入るし しかしね
あとは大変だから じゃあやめましょうと
別に金が欲しくなくなったわけじゃないんです
あの脅し 罰が怖いんです
だからみんなあの非道徳的なこと
不道徳なことは知らない
しないだけで 別にいい人間になったわけじゃないんですよ
というわけで 何かの見張り役をがですかね
必要とする 道徳の世界で
このモラルの世界では
誰かが見張り役がどうしても必要なんです
見張っておかないとやっちゃうんです
見張り役がなければ それ
バレなければ良いという考えで道徳を破るんです
これは事実でしょ バレなきゃいいということで
世の中は道徳を破っているんです
世界一正しいことをやっているアメリカでも
ウォーターゲート事件というものがあったでしょ
明らかにだらしない恐ろしいことで
今もいろいろやってますけど
まだバレてないんだから大丈夫です
そこまでは善人です 正邪なんです
だから世の中っていうのはそんなもんで
バレなきゃもうすごい胸張って
もう清らかな政治とかね
命かけてなんとかとか言い張ったりするんですけど
やってることバレちゃうと何か黙って下がるんです
だから見張り役が必要なんですね
道徳には それで世の中で見張り役あるんですかね
まあ大体はみんな別にそんな道徳破ったりしないでしょう
やっぱり見張り役はあるんですよ
具体に例えば警察 でしょ
誰かが道徳破っちゃうと
すぐ警察を呼ぶ だからもうみんなやろうとはしない
それから社会ね 周りもそうでしょう
自分住んでる社会で 周りの人々にバレますからね
で 気を付ける 結局は人間互いに監視し合ってるんですよ
だからなんとか なんとか
それなりに平和で無事いられますよ
でもよく考えて みんな互いに監視し合ってるんだっていうか
すごい気持ち悪いでしょうね
本当はお互いにみんな監視やってるんです
だから悪いことをしない
監視してるという気持ちは全くないんでしょ
でもこちらどなたかいきなり立って何か悪いことしようと思ったらどうなるんですかね
例えばいきなり例えば私を怒鳴りつけたりすると
気持ちあってもやらないんですよ
みんなの目をというか
目線を考えて やっぱり監視ですよ
はい 弱みの続き これから時代によって変わるんですね
皆さんは若い時の道徳と今の道徳って変わってるでしょうしね
これも弱みなんですよ
だからなんで今の道徳をそんなに真剣に守る必要があるのかと
もうちょっと時間経てばどれ変わるでしょうということもあるんです
社会によっても違う道徳になる
そこで自分がいる社会が変わって
別な社会に行ったら別な道徳ですね
例えば行儀よくちゃんと畳の上で座って食事するのはもうずっと立派なことだと
小さい時からもう慣らしていて
外国に行ってしまったら箸 1本も見つからないと
そこで箸を探せば みんな何やってるんでしょうかと
周りがいろんなことを言うかもしれません
それでそちらのやり方でやらなくちゃいけないんです
だから社会が変わっちゃうと
もうせっかく守ってきた道徳ももう変わってしまうんですよ
で 宗教信仰によっても道徳が変わる
これすごい厄介なことなんです
2つの宗教を信仰している二人がなかなか仲友達になれないんですよ
だって二人の信仰が違うんだから
宗教違うんだから それぞれ道徳違うんですよ
で 個人の思考によっても変わる
また 個人もいろんなくだらんこと考えるんだからね
例えば 親がいくら道徳を説教しても
子供が嫌やと言ってもう逆らう時もあるでしょうに
そんな考え方には乗りませんよと
そういうことで学校で
なかなか規則決めるのは難しい
子供たちが別な意見でいると
もう大変トラブルが起こる
会社で社長 課長がいろんな決まりを決めても
社員たちが反対しちゃうと
もう別な考えを動かしちゃうと
もう動き出すと もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
だから 個人の考え方で変わることも道徳の弱みなんです
それから道徳に説得力
説得力がないんですよ
これすごい弱みなんです
人が必ずそれを守るようにという説得力がないんです
だから誰も真面目に聞いてくれないんですよ
嘘をついてはいけませんと言うんですけど
全然説得力がないんです
子供にそんなこと言うとうるさいと
特に学校なんかではね
もう教師たちがもうゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャ
これはやってはいけない
これはあれはやってはいけないとかね
これはこういう決まりだから
これはこういう決まりだからって誰も聞いてないんです
その時 親が説教する時は全然子供は聞いてないんです
なぜかというと 説得力がないんですよ
これ 親がダメというわけじゃないんですよ
道徳そのものに説得力がないんです
じゃあ皆様試してみてください
絶対嘘をついてはならないと
はっきりと相手に言えますか
言えないんですよ みんなそう言ってるんだからとか
なんとか言うだけ 説得力がないんです
破る努力だけ目立つが
守るための努力は不足ない
大体道徳の世界ではみんな必死になっていかに破るかっていうことしか考えてないんですよ
この間すごい小さな子供と会ったことがありまして
で 私とはべったり仲良くなって
この子はいろんなことを言うんですね
言うことをもう私に正直に言う
これはもう別にどうってことではなくて
私に向かって嘘は言えない
これ聞いて 私はこれ親が知ったらどんなことになるでしょうという怪我足すことなんです
時々まだちっちゃい子供だからね
親にしてみればもう宝物でも
それで私はなんとなく
まあもう世の中ってこういうものだ
なんか親に文句を言ったんだよ
子供が言ったら これはあなたに言わないこといっぱいあるんだよ
だってあんたもそうでしょうと
親に言わないこといっぱいあるでしょ
だから何やと言ったところでちょっと落ち着いちゃったんです
親にも言ったんですよ
だから私の子供だから何でもわかってると思っちゃったら良くないんだと
わからないことってのは小さい時からいっぱいあるんだと
それしか私に言えないんですよ
この子はこういうことを言ってるなんてことはもう
言えないんだからね だからやっぱり小さい時からもういかに破るかっていうこと
いかに悪いことをするのかっていうことしか頭の中にないんですよ
子供ならいかに勉強さぼって遊ぶのかとかね
親に隠れてどうやって何か悪ふざけができるのかっていうことしか考えてないんです
これが大人も同じ 女性も男性もみんな同じなんです
だから世の中でよく目立ってるのは
この見事に上手に道徳を破った話ばっかりなんです
守るっていうことは全然
こうすれば 例えば政治献金の問題はこうすれば直るんではないかという話は一向に出てこないでしょ
今国会で喋ってるでしょうね
必死になって ではどんなカラクリでまた迂回金とかなんとか迂回金意味は分かりませんけども
あまりにも聞きすぎて覚えた言葉でどうやって取れるのかという話しか
見事に読めるんですね
だから道徳守る気持ちはもう誰も人類にはないんです
目立ってるのは破る破るっていうことが
それも道徳の一番大きい弱みなんです
だからずっと格言の中で書いたんです
道徳っていうのはお呼びでない客ですと
我々の人生に 我々の人生に入り込んでいるお呼びでない客なんです
はい しかし この客を追い出せないんですよ
出て行けって言えば簡単でしょうに
私は道徳を守りたくないんだぞと
客は追い出せないんですよ
嫌な客なのに追い出せない
それが個人のエゴの問題ですよ
結局は なぜエゴかというと
自分が道徳守りたくないんですよ
しかし あの人が道徳破っちゃうと私が困るんです
私はバレなきゃ人のものを盗みたいんだけど
私の家に空き巣に入っちゃうと
これとんでもないことなんです
それであるテレビで見たんですけど
ある番組で あの ものすごい
もうもうもうもう 四百件以上
このいろんな家に入って
もう泥棒盗むんです それでも億単位にも値段になっていて
盗んだものも必要ということじゃなくて
盗んでは家に置いておく
だから家はもう盗んだ品物いっぱいなんですね
何でもありき テレビ自体ってもう何台もあるとかね
あれこれまあ十 丁寧に整理整頓して盗んだもの
しかし その人の窓に鍵が 四つ入ってあるんです
窓にも鍵 それだけじゃないんです
何か金具でつけてチェーンをかけてるんです
だから窓を割っても入らないし
窓を破って引っ張っても引っ張れないんです
それからいろいろ警報作ってるんだから
それ鳴らし 鳴いちゃいますからね
玄関も鍵 鍵と あの あれ
なんて言いますかね あのカチンと止まるやつ
錠前ですね  錠前も何枚かある
いい泥棒さんですよ 正直で
私は徹底的に空き巣なら盗むんですけど
私のものはもう 一本 糸一本でも盗むなよと
だからその人も盗むなかれという道徳は持ってるんです
私ではなくて あなたは盗むなかれと
だから泥棒する私たちにはそんなことはどうでもいいんだから
その道徳なんかないんだよと公で胸張って言えない
言わないんですよ 本当は嫌な客なんですけど
それがエゴでしょ だから自分のエゴだから道徳を追い出せなくなってるんです
人が道徳を破るとき 自分が困ることは多々ありますからね
だから否定する気にはならない
いや 守ってはないんだけど
否定はしない 自分のことを棚に上げて他人に守ってもらう
もらいたい行為こそが道徳なのです
これが定義です やっと定義にたどり着きました
道徳っていうのは 他人に守ってもらうものなんです
自分が守るものじゃないんです
これは世の中にある道徳なんですよ
これで全てわかるでしょ
みんな学校でも道徳なんか授業があったりしてうまくいかない
世の中もいろんな道徳は道徳は何ぞやと哲学もある
でも誰一人も何言ってるのかと
ばっかりでしょうし それ
それ何言ってもなかなか道徳的な平和な法律を守る社会も築くこともできないし
だから人類にとって未だに道徳っていうことは解決できないすごい難しい問題ですけど
ほら ブッダの智慧から見てください
簡単です わかりやすいです
他人に 他人に守ってもらいたい行為なんです
だからその ギクシャクしているんです
ああ 質問とかあったらね
覚えてメモ書いて後で聞いてください
いくらか反論できる言葉は結構わざと書いておきました
はい 進みます 説教師たちがモラリストが
ただまあこれ意味だけですね
モラリストが溢れている
ほとんどの人に他人に道徳を押し付けた経験があると思う
あるでしょう 他人にはすごい厳しく道徳を押し付けると
自分に言われると嫌な気分になる
しかし 自分に言われてえらい嫌な気分になるんです
他人に言う時はすごい胸を張って言うんです
人類がモラリスト 道徳主義者ですが
世の中から悪だけは常に健在です
世の中はどんな人の顔を見てもモラリストですよ
だったら世の中で悪あるはずがないでしょうに
でも世の中で目立ってるのは悪だけなんです
悪はずっと健在ですよ
わかりやすい だって道徳っていうのは私が守るものじゃなくて
相手が守るものでしょ
相手が守るべきものですね
この状態もまたモラリストから偽善だと命名されている
これはね もう何と言いますか
なんか言葉が出てこない
こんなことやってるにも関わらず
偉そうに だって偽善という言葉まで使ってる
作ってるんです 私は人類には偽善という言葉を使う権利はないと思ってますけど
そこまでインチキやってるんです
偽善という単語 だって自分でしょ
自分といえば全ての人間でしょ
他人に守ってほしい あんた守りなさい
あんた守りなさいと 自分が守ってないんだから
これ偽善でしょうね しかし
私が偽善者よと絶対言わないんです
世の中は偽善者ばっかりやと
だって自分が言ったことやってくれないんだから
嘘をつくなよ 人を騙すなよと言っても
相手が嘘をつくし 人を騙すでしょうに
でも言う時ははい よくわかりましたと認めて帰るでしょうに
だから他人に向かって偽善者だとも言ったりする
とんでもないやつですよ
人間っていうのは はい
次に行きます テーマ変わると思います
だったら道徳はなぜあるのでしょうかっていう問題
あの一つは答え出したとは思います
あの 何であるのかと 人が道徳を守らないと私が困るんだからね
そうするとあなたも困る
あの人も困る だから道徳っていうのを客を追い出せないという
この真似から 真似 何て言いますか
真似から猿 客を出ていけと言えない勇気がないんです
それは一つの理由であって
それからもっと あの 中に入って考えます
非道徳っていうのは 悪が道徳
善の生みの親です ですから
道徳は誰が生んでいるのかということ
不道徳が生んでるんですよ
これ親なんですよ 何か矛盾しているんでしょうかね
ですね 嘘 それからこの相対
これから相対論に入ります
なぜ相対論に入ったのかということは
ここからわかると思います
嘘つきがいるからこそ嘘つきてはならないことになるでしょう
だから嘘ついてはならないという道徳を生んだのは嘘なんです
嘘つくことなんです その行為が生みの親なんです
人は他人のものを盗むから盗んではならないことになるんです
だから盗むことは悪いですよと
盗まないことは素晴らしい道徳だよと言ってるのは
その道徳は生んだのは盗みそのものなんです
他を殺すからこそ殺してはならないと決める
人は全然生命を殺してないんだったら
殺すなかれよ 素晴らしい生き方よと言えますかね
言えないでしょう だから覚えてください
道徳の生みの親がこの不道徳というか
悪なんです はい それでまた道徳の親について
社会に悪がなければ善の意味が消えてしまう
世の中に全くの悪がない人は全然嘘もつかないわ
人のものを盗らないわ
正直で真面目で謙虚でいるんだったら
もう道徳はいらん 消えてしまう
道徳主義者になってみると
悪魔の尊さに なんていうか
無意識的に気づくという
それで道徳主義者いるでしょ
モラリスト 世の中にあれキャーキャーキャーキャーキャーキャーキャーキャーガチャガチャガチャガチャ
よくよく喋るでしょう
本も書きます かなり安い本まで
あの皆様 大学なんか哲学なんか勉強なさったならば
道徳のエティクスの本もかなりたくさん大量にあるでしょう
さっぱり何言ってるかわからないんです
とにかく難しい単語を並べて書いてるだけ
それで道徳主義者が一番発見しているのは
この悪魔の尊さなんですよ
これはだから私はちょっと辛口で言ってるけど
別に悪魔いるかいないかということではなくて
あの 一般的に言えばね
まあこのモラリストこそが心の中すごい危ないということかね
ものすごい悪を重々と感じているんですね
だから ギュウギュウと感じているんだからこそ
道徳的な考え方は次から次へと生まれてしまうんです
世の中で悪がなければ
道徳主義者たちは失業する
けど 昔 ソ連 ソ連で書かれた立派な物語
あるいはノーベル賞を取ったトールストイか誰かと思いますけどね
書いた小さな物語がありまして
ある村で神父さんがいて
ものすごい真剣な真面目な神父さんで
かなり能力 超能力もある
だからどこかに 悪魔に悪魔が乗り移っちゃうと憑依しちゃうと
この神父さんが行って聖水かけてお祈りして
もう悪魔追い出しちゃうんですね
だから悪魔なんか大嫌い
どこでも悪魔が働いてるなとわかったら
すぐそちらに行って もう徹底的に悪魔を追い出しちゃって
人は助けてあげる 立派な神父さんです
そこであの日 もう夜でも昼でも真夜中でも
いつでも呼ばれたら行く
ものすごい立派な人 それであの日
この神父さんが夜雪 もう冬だから
ソ連だからね で行くと
なんか道路で人が倒れてるんです
黒い服を着て ものすごい傷
血まみれ 神父さんがすごい慈しみというか
もう優しい方だから あ
これ大変だ で 下がってみたんですね
下がってみたら かなり怪我して
それでキリスト教の中でこの悪魔と戦う
戦うの天使がいるんですね
あんた何でしたっけ？ ガブリエル
で ちょっと振り返してみると
尾っぽもちょっとあるんですね
ただ もうこれ悪魔だと
そしたら悪魔 ものすごくもう死にかけて
もうもう泣きながら もうガブリエルにふっ飛ばされてやられちゃったと
私は死にかけているから
言ったら ずっと悪魔と戦ってきた神父さんがすごいいい気分だって
よし ガブリエル聖人がよくやってくれたと
聖人じゃなくて天使が
言って その人そのまま置いといて
もう死に死にかけるようにしておいて
無視して出かけようとしたんだって
悪魔現に目の前にいるんだから
もう死んだ方がいいでしょう
すると悪魔がまた神父さん
ちょっと待ってくださいと
あなたは私を助けるしかないんだよ
あなたに他の道は 何言うんですかと
あなたは神に逆らったんだから
あなたのせいで人々は神を信仰していないのではないか
あなたの誘惑でほとんど人々は地獄に落ちているのではないか
というわけで あなたは死んだ方が神に対する愛情でもあって
人々に対する憐れみでもある
そしたら悪魔があのね
私がいるんだからあなた仕事して食べてるんだよ
もし私がいなかったら
あなたの仕事も終わりと
教会の仕事も終わりやと
あんた方追い出されますよ
あんたこれから誰に向かって何の説教するんですかと
聖書を読んでごらんと
読んだことないでしょ
と ずっと私の悪口でしょうと
もし私が死んじゃったら
あんた方何言うんでしょうかと
あの聖書そのものの意味がなくなっちゃいますよ
それでどうなるかというと
誰も神のことを気にしないとね
平気でへっちゃらでいるんだと
私が誘惑するんだからこそ
みんな神のことを気にしなくちゃいけないんではないかと
私に誘惑されて地獄に落ちるんだからこそ
人間頑張らなくちゃいけないんではないかと
だから実際生き続けて
永久的に生き続けてほしいのは私ではないかと
あの神じゃないでしょと
言うと 考えたらその通りでしょうに
それで悪魔を運んで あの白い服がね
ずーっと血まみれで この小説だから美しく書いてあったんです
彼の雪のごとく白い服がじっと血に血が落ちて落ちて落ちて
体重染みてというか 濡れていくのに
神父さんは悪魔を運んで教会に持っていったと
という あの これは別に起きた話じゃなくて
ドストエフスキーという方がもう立派な小説だからね
もう人間の論理をね 見事に語られているなと
私はすごいちいちゃな子供の頃
勉強読んだものだから
もうかなり昔のはもう
でもやっぱり覚えているんですよ
すごいいい物語で だから道徳書籍的なけど
悪魔に食わせてるような感じ
嘘をつくことはこれほど悪いやという場合は
悪い人がいなかったらね
そういうわけで 神と悪魔の戦いは古からあるのです
まあ今日で神という言葉っていうのは道徳主義を表すために使ったので
宗教の信仰対象とはなんてありませんと
ただちょっと表現的に使っただけなんですけどね
人間は良い行為を模索するのは本来の悪を知っているから
感じているからです 知ってるっていうのはちょっとおかしいんですから
感じてるからです 人間はいつでも良い行為って何なのかとよく模索してるでしょう
もしかすると心の中で持ってる悪
悪をね 知ってるかも 知ってるのはないと思いますけど
感じてはいる もしかすると私は危ないという
だから道徳を探してるんです
しかし 他人の行為を見る時のみ発見するのです
問題は人の行為見ると
これはあかんよと すぐ発見する
それエゴで発見するんです
こんなことやったら私が困るよ
他の人も困るよと言うんです
だから人間 道徳は本当に発見していますよ
発見していますが それが他人を見て発見しているんです
自分の行為は常に正しいという前提です
ですから 考え出した道徳は他人に押し付けるべきもののものなので
だからどうしようもないんです
我々発見している道徳は
あの道徳自体間違ってないんですよ
全部ではないんだけど
一部はあるんです しっかりした道徳
しかし役に立たない それもそれは他人に押し付けるものだからね
例えば人殺すなかれというのは人類みんな思ってるでしょうに
それは正しいんです でも役に立たない
あんなのはでたらめ あれは自分で人殺さないではなくて
他人に言うおせっかいだからね
だから機能しないんですよ
世の中本当に立派な男ですよ
人殺してはいけませんとかね
他人を助けましょうとか
隣人を愛しましょうとかね
立派な言葉なんですけど
すべてくだらない無意味なんです
結局は 機能しない しかし
道徳自体は正しいんです
発見したものですから
しかし そこにはそういう問題があります
はい 次に行きます 神の言葉を人間に伝える場合も
あなたはやりなさいというスタンスがあります
まぁ あらゆる聖書たくさんありますね
読んでみてください あなたやりなさいという調子で言ってるんです
それでこの行を書いたところで
ちょっと思い出したんですけど
旧約聖書ではなんか神はちょっとモーセやらアブラハムやらちょっとからかってる時もあります
お前もやったらどうですか？という態度でモーセアブラハムは他人にものすごく声を高くして言ってるんですけど
自分のことはだらしないというかね
誰でしたっけ なんかすごい年取って息子が生まれて割礼しなかったんですね
みんなに言ってやりなさい
神はそんな命令しているんだぞと言って
自分の息子にはやりたくない
痛いんだから それで神が怒って
もう子供を私にいけにえにしてください
で なんかただそういったところで
まぁしょうがなく なんかいけにえにしたと
いけにえにした まぁ一応そのことはやろうとしたとか
そういう悔い改めの話があるんです
だからそこで私は何を読み取ったかというと
やっぱりお前もやったらどうですか？というね
人に押し付けるだけではなくて
という気持ちかも でも新約聖書ではないんです
そんなのお前らもやりなさい
私は神ですから という態度で言ってるんです
で 旧約聖書は神が語ったんじゃなくて
そこら辺にいたくだらない連中が言ったもんなんです
神の言葉を聞いて 新約聖書になってくると
神そのものが喋ってるんですね
イエスという名前で だから君たちが守りなさいという調子になっているのです
矛盾というのは 旧約聖書ではそんなろくな道徳ないんですよ
恐ろしいんです もう憎しみやら怒りやら
もう叱咤やら何でもありき
新約聖書になってくると素晴らしい人間論なんですよ
すごく美しい 優しい人間像
語ってますが 態度はそんな態度ない
汝ら守れと だから人間には道徳っていうのはそう簡単に言えるもんじゃないんです
だからその失敗は我々もやってる失敗でしょ
家のお母さんもお父さんもやってるでしょ
失敗は 子供にはビシビシ言う
自分では自分はやらせない
それで子供は真面目に聞いてくれないという結果は
我々も味わっているでしょうに
そういうことで 親がいくら踏ん張っても
世の中の子供は良くなるわけじゃないんです
親を見て大きくなるんだから
いくらなんでも だから世の中こんなもんなんですね
それ親を見てちゃんと成長した結果なんです
親の話は聞いてないんです
だから聖書になっても
新約聖書になっても同じ問題だから
やっぱりキリスト教 世の中のものすごい広げたんですけど
道徳的な社会は作れなかったんですね
戦争 戦いの社会なんですね
戦争が広げただけ よりしっかりとイスラム教は戦争は広げるんですね
はい えーと まあそんな話は置いといて
結局はモラリストに他人の粗しか見えないことになってしまう
他人の粗しか見えない
人間の弱み 悪は 大好きであること
いくら言っても 目を離した瞬間でやってしまう性格なんかは見えない
だからモラリストに見えないのは
人間の弱み見えないんですよ
人間っていうのは悪は大好きだよと
皆様は子供にすごく好かれて欲しければ
子供のやんちゃぶりやらね
悪いこと好きなことを褒めてあげてください
すごくもう仲良くしてくれるんですよ
こんなことやってはいけませんと言っちゃうと
もうおじいさんおばあさんからもう逃げてしまうんです
つい言っちゃうんだから
私もじじいなんですけど
子供にそれだけは言わないんです
すぐ仲良くしてくれる
私は何言うかというと
お前勇気がないでやっちゃえと
それってのを言います
どうせ悪いことするのはもう仕事でしょうと
それ好きでしょうと それで仲良くしてくれる
しかし 皆様よりしっかり育てることができます
ものすごく正直で だからあの子供でもたった 1 日で
絶対誰にも言わないと思いますけどね
何のことなく私の背中に乗って
もう手を回して いろいろ耳元にいろんないいことを言われます
だからそれ理解して 俺もこんなのは別にまあいいんじゃないかと
誰でもやってるんだからねっていうことで
私も お前そんな年で変でしょうと言ったことは言えなかったんです
ですからもう私ならもう何のことなく
もう理想的に心育てることはできます
そこへそういうやり方なんです
だからこのモラリストたちが人間
人間っていうのは悪が大好きだよと
酒やめるよりは酒飲むのは大好きだよと
賭け事をやめるよりは
できれば仕事も辞めて賭け事で大儲けしたいっていうのは正直な気持ちだよと
不倫したくてたまらんやと
それが否定するんで それが事実なのに
だから道徳 あのモラリストにその人間の弱み見えないんですね
粗ばっかし見えるんです
何やってるんでしょうかね
あの人結婚もしているのに
他の女に手を出しているんではないか
信頼できない そんな人は
自分が何者か全然考えてもいない
モラリストが世の中で悪があればあるほど興奮する
需要が増えて商売繁盛だと思いますけどね
まあそんなもんですよ
だからモラルの生みの親は悪である
はい 次 それから逆に言えば
善人のあれに 殺し 嘘 盗み
不倫 噂 それで戦いなどが良くないというために
不道徳そのものを厳しく認識しなくてはならない
善人でもよろしいし 道徳主義者でもいいんだけど
その人々はみんなに言わなくちゃいかんでしょ
殺しは良くない 噂 嘘は良くない
盗みは良くない 不倫は良くないと言わなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だからその人の頭の中で殺す
殺すことやら 噂 嘘のことやら
不倫のことやら ぐちゃぐちゃ考えていないと
かなり哀れみなんですよ
他人の悪行 行為をなくそうとする気持ちは
他を愛することだと自分のことを正当化する
それで悪いことには 自分が人のことを哀れんで愛してるんだ
だから言ってるんだとよく言ってるでしょ
あなたのことを大事に思ってるんだから言ってるんではないかと
かわいそうです だから自分が正しいという危ないことをするんですよ
まだわからない  一応言います
先に あの 人間の一番大きい間違いは
自分が正しいと思うことなんです
自分がだらしない 正しくないとはっきりと認識した時点で
初めて良い人間になるんです
だから それがブッダの言葉で
それがあって 私はその
そのの上からずっと喋ってるので
お釈迦様の言葉言わないで
だからお釈迦様の言葉を覚えておけば一応わかりやすいと思います
もし善人になりたければ
まず自分が悪人であることを明確に自覚することなんです
それからもう徐々にいい人間になるんです
しかし 何かなくそうとすることは
それがあってはならないという気持ちです
それでモラリストが嘘があってはならないと思うでしょうに
嘘をなくそう 世の中から
人殺しやめましょう 強盗やめましょうという風に数々言っているでしょうに
だから彼らがこの何か世の中で存在してはいけないと思っているのです
それは破壊 怒り 壊す行動ですよ
結局は それに気づいてない
自分が破壊的な考え方を持ってるんですよ
でも建物破壊しましょうとかね
あの ワールドトレードセンターを破壊しようと思っちゃうと
これが良くないんですね
その代わりにテロ扱いされるでしょ
その代わりに やっぱり世の中の悪事を破壊しましょうということにするわけです
そうしちゃうと テロではなくて
善人やと勲章をもらうんです
同じ心理なんです はい
次は同じですね 従って
善人は愛の なんでそれは？鎧に騙されて怒り憎しみを隠している可能性が大きい
愛という鎧に騙されて
心の中で怒り 憎しみというものを隠しているんです
本人は知らない だから憐れみなんです
人殺すもの 戦争に挑む者が
自分が敵を憎しんでいること
怒っていることを知っている
悪いことを 例えば人殺す人はよく知っ私はあいつを憎い
だから殺す 可愛いんだから殺すってことはありえないんです
戦争に行く人々もたくさん人を殺すんですけど
あの連中は敵だから大嫌いだ
見たところで殺すぞという風にはっきりしているんです
モラリストが夜 夜 モラリストが世直し屋
モラリストか世直し屋が自分も何かを憎しんでることに気づけない
それで世直し屋さんも何か憎しんでるんですよ
それに気づかない 自分には愛があるんだと言っちゃうんです
これが危ないというところなんです
だから戦争に行ってる兵隊さんよりは危ないんです
兵隊さんは正直なんです
あいつは敵だから殺すんだよ
単純で モラリスト 原理主義者たちは結構危険な存在です
症状が出ない病は死をもたらす
でしょ 例えば 胃がちょっと何か変なことになっちゃって
痛くてたまらん場合はお医者さんに言うでしょうね
しかし 胃には癌があって
全然症状がない ご飯も食べるし
もう結構健康でいるし
やがてああ疲れた なんか体力がない
ご飯食べられなくなったといったところで
もうダメだというんですよ
だから症状が出ない病気っていうのはとんでもない危険です
死ぬ だからモラリストの場合は
自分も憎しみ怒りを持っているんだということに気づかない
病気を持ってるんだと
だから世の中でこの原理主義っていうのは一番危ないでしょ
ものすごい危険で あまりも宗教なんか信仰なんかにしがみついちゃうと
もう日本でも人を殺すなり
いろんなことも 日本だったらもう明らかに来明確でしょうね
何か宗教組織あったら
もう何か何か犯罪で 終わって
それまたそれ正当化する
面白いことはいまだにこの私
私が喋ってるテーラワーダ仏教の会員の数よりは
麻原彰晃の信者さんの数が未だに多いんです
ね だからあれほど悪いことしているのに
やっぱり正当化して正当化して
最近も何かね 人を殴ったりして大変なことにしたりする
修行僧とかね 本当に危ないです
そういう精神的にもう頭おかしいんだからね
そういうことです それからちょっとテーマ変わります
わかってくれない道徳の相対性
これから仏教の話 今まで言ったのは世間の話
たまたまブッダの言葉も入れましたけど
一応世間はそんなもんだよと
この講義一つ終わるとき
でも皆様はもう大学なんかは10年道徳論研究したよりは理解できると思います
だからよく考えた方がいいんです
なかなか世の中でないんです
そういう風に明確に分析するっていうこと
ちょっと量が多すぎて皆様にはちょっと消化しにくいかもしれませんだけど
でもこれはもうかなりの量なんですけど
とにかく覚えた方が役に立つと思います
これからブッダの話 道徳は非道徳行為が生んで育てるものだとわかってくれない
皆様今聞いたんだからね
わかるでしょうと 世の中わかってないんですよ
道徳道徳って それ誰が生んだんですか？というと
非道徳 不道徳生んでるんです
盗みがあるから与えることは良いとのことになっています
嘘があるから正直は良いということになっているんです
だから善先に善前に善悪があるはずです
しかし 人はこの相対性を理解していないから
言葉さえもないのです
これ ちょっとわからない
いわゆる言葉もないんですよ
この善に言葉がないんです
悪には言葉があるんです
この世の中に これちょっとわかりにくいんですけど
それから説明します わかってくれない道徳の相対性
殺しの反対 これ言葉がないこと
では 殺しの反対の行為は何と言えばいいんですか？言葉がある？殺さないことしか言えないでしょう
言葉さえもないんです
だから道徳道徳と言ったっても
結局悪しかないんですよ
だから殺しっていうことが不道徳でしょ
ではそちらの相対的な反対のことなんですかね
これはないでしょう 盗みの反対の行為
いくらか仏教を勉強しているならば知っていると思いますけど
こちらもいっぱいいますけどね
これで私は勉強しているレベルがわかりますけどね
では 盗みって不動とかあるでしょ
そちらの反対の行為はなんですかね
善行為は 盗まないことしか頭に浮かばないでしょう
嫉妬の反対の行為は？嫉妬することは悪いでしょ
では 嫉妬しないでは何をすればいいんですか？ない
で 恨みの反対の行為 邪淫の反対の行為
強悪業の反対の行為 欲怒りの反対の行為とか
言葉さえないんですよ
それぐらい悪の影響力は強いんです
いわゆる人間には考えられないんですよ
単語も作ってないんです
だから道徳を考えた人々の頭の中で
悪の概念しかなかったんです
人の粗 他人の粗しかなかったんです
だから経験してないものだから単語がないんです
例えば美味しいという単語があるのかというと
美味しさを経験しているからでしょ
なんで寒いという単語があるんですかね
寒さは経験しているからでしょ
寒いの反対の言葉はなんでしたっけ？熱い
暑いか暖かいでしょ どう？あるでしょうに
寒いの反対の言葉あるのに
なんで殺しの反対の言葉ないんですかね
蘇生  え？蘇生？今考えたでしょ
蘇生って何？どういう意味？ 死にそうな人を助ける
生かす  だから人が死んでくれないと道徳はできないんですね
死にそうじゃないとダメですね
え？でしょ そう簡単じゃないんです
私は泣くかける義眼には
盗みの反対は 布施はどうですか？布施
それはまあ これは合ってますけどね
布施というよりは協力するっていうことですけどね
正しい 助け合いや協力するということが反対の言葉なんです
他はもう頑張っても意味がないんですよ
ないんです 言葉は はい
次 なすべからずだけの道徳
道徳言えば何でもやるべからず
なすべからず そればっかしでしょ
やるなやるなやるなと言うばっかしでうるさいんですよ
道徳といえば あれ あれやこれやとやるなかれという話はほとんどです
ダメダメばかり言われても
行動的な生き物である人間には守り難いものです
それわかるでしょ？気持ちは
人間っていうのは生き物で
何かやりたい したいんですよ
何かしたい 何をすればいいかというと
ダメ ダメ ダメと言っちゃうと
何の意味もないでしょうに
それで私は人間として何かやりたい
生きることって何かやることだから
では教えてちょうだい
私は何やればいいかといったら
これダメ あれダメ これダメ
あれダメばっかりでしょうに
だから世の中の道徳っていうのはいい加減なんです
これこれをやれと言われた方が落ち着くのです
みんなちゃんと真面目にやってくれますよ
君はこれやりなさいと言った方が
しかし やるなかれという人も
何をやれば良いかと考えたこともありませんね
これやってはいけない
あれやってはいけないと言うだけで
ではやってはいいもの何なのかって考えてないんです
はい 次 ブッダも苦労する
で これ単語ないんだから
お釈迦様にも大変苦労なんですよ
長い文章だから もしかすると文法間違いとかあるかもしれませんだけど
人間が使う言葉ではわかりやすく
言葉でわかりやすく語るのは常識ですが
道徳になるとポジティブな単語はなかったのです
ブッダにしても だって人間の単語を調べたらポジティブな言葉がないんです
だからブッダもよく否定形容詞を使っていたが
できるだけに肯定的な用語でやるべきことを語り続けたのです
本当にすごい苦労をなさったと思います
単語を調べても調べても否定形ばっかしで
というか もうやってはいけない単語ばっかしで
ではやっていいっていうものは何よと
ない それでお釈迦様にもしょうがなく
怒るなかれとかね 嫉妬するなかれとか言うんだけど
単語あるならばポジティブ単語は全部使ったんです
これやるべきこと それで
一つ違う例なんですけど
不貪などの否定語を使うときも
それがただ何かがないという意味ではなく
何かを育てるという意味なのです
例えば仏教でいう三毒
貪瞋痴ありますね これで三毒に対して不貪不瞋不痴と言うんですね
貪瞋痴というのは欲と怒りと無知なんです
それで ではそれ悪だったら善は不貪不瞋不痴とわざわざと不不入れたんです
それでお釈迦様があなた方には単語もないんだよということを言ってるんです
あなた方は考えたこともないんだと
あなた方にわからないんだと
この不貪の状態は 欲のない状態
だから未だかつてない教えだと
これは 初めて発見しているんだよ
では 不貪っていうのは欲がないという状態じゃないんです
何かすごい力なんです
例えば欲張っちゃうとすごい力でしょ？あれが欲しい
これが欲しい とにかく死んでもあれが自分のものにするぞというエネルギーあるでしょうに
不貪はそれより何倍もエネルギーなんです
でもそれって何かとわからないんです
しかし ブッダの不貪不瞋不痴っていうのは何もないって意味じゃないんです
すごいポジティブ的なエネルギーなんです
しかし 単語はない ブッダが道徳の相対性を発見してあったのです
ブッダだけは道徳は相対的ということはよく発見したんです
だから そういうところでお釈迦様は苦労するんです
言葉選ぶときでも やっぱりこの人間どもは道徳喋ってるんだけど
わかってないんだと だからブッダは堂々と言うんですよ
自分こそが初めて世に道徳を語っているんだと
これが初めてやと 道徳はなかった
はい えーと もう一つ例
大弟子サーリプッタ尊者がお釈迦様の一番目の弟子なんですよ
知の大臣にされた 出家に戒律を定めてくださいと頼んだところでお待ちなさいと断ったのです
あるエピソードがあって
サーリプッタ尊者に聞いたサーリプッタ尊者がお釈迦様に聞いたんですよ
お釈迦様はブッダのこの偉大なる教えは長生きするか早く亡くなるか
その理由は長生きするならば理由は何なのかと
早く亡くなるんだ その理由は何なのかといったら
まあブッダが道徳を設定しておくならば長生きしますよと
そうすると人間がわかりやすくて
あ これこれやらないで
これこれやればいいとよくわかる
もしブッダが道徳を設定しなかったならば
ブッダが亡くなった時点で仏教は消えちゃうんだと
ただサーリプッタ尊者
それだったら人類に偉大なる幸福をもたらすこの教えを我々からも続けてほしいと
だからお願いしますと出家に戒律を設定してください
そうしたら お釈迦様が待ちなさい
出家サンガの中で間違いが現れない限り
ブッダは戒律道徳を定めないと説かれたのです
ペラペラペラペラあれやるなこれやるなっていうものじゃないんだと
悪が現れたらそこで反対のことをしてあげる
だから道徳はやっぱりの生みの親が悪なんです
お釈迦様もよくそれをご存知でしたからね
もし出家した比丘が嘘をついたならば
そこでけしからんことをやっているんではなく
これから比丘たる者は嘘をついてはいけない
嘘をついちゃうと道徳を破ったことになると
戒律を決めてです ある欲張りのお坊さんが
いろんなところに行って説法して
信者さんからお布施もらっちゃうんです
そうすると若いお坊さんたちも
この人は説法上手だから
そちらに行って説法を聞いたりする
すると この人は君たちにもお布施もしないで説法ばっかり聞くつもりですかと
というと 先生も我々も出家だからと部屋にいたら
ざっと君にこの衣もあるでしょう
君にこれ杖があるでしょう
君にこれこれカップあるでしょう
それでもどうですかと言って
それをまた持っていくんです
そこで一つの村で もう説法が終わって
もう荷車にいっぱい荷物を運んで持っていく
これ別に何か戒律を破っているという
もらったものを持っていくんだからね
サミたちに若者たちにこれこれというのは別に道徳違反ではないし
それでも人々はこれを何だと
この人は他人に説法するんだけど
自分が欲張りではないか
いうとお釈迦様はそこでもう悪が現れたでしょ
それで戒律で禁止したんです
いらんものは持つ持つものじゃないんだ
いらないものをもらったら
それはサンガのみんなのものであって
個人財産ではありません
そこで新しい戒律が現れたんです
だから今 まだに出家世界では自分の衣とかね
自分の鉢とか そういう自分体で使うもの以外
末とかね 個人財産はあってはならない
いますよ これ私のものと思っていたっても
仏教の国では法律的にはそうじゃないんです
亡くなったらもう全部サンガに返さなくちゃいけないと
あるいはサンガの誰かがこれ必要やと言ったら
はいはい どうぞと言ってあげなくちゃいけない
それでまあそういうきめ細かい戒律まで
でもやっぱり悪が現れたところで決めたんです
悪がないと別に善もないということなんです
やはり悪がないと善もないという事実をブッダのみ悟っていたのです
はい 次 早く終わろうと思います
ブッダは偽善をなくす
では偽善という問題 仏教では道徳は他人に押し付けるものではないとする
今までの人類の道徳は私ではなくて
あなた方は守りなさいということでしょうね
人間の正直なところ 道徳を守りたくないでしょう
ブッダはそれを変えるんです
道徳っていうのは他人に押し付けるものではない
道徳は自分の悪を発見して
それに対する解毒剤を自分で飲むことです
道徳っていうのは他人に言うものじゃなくて
自分の心を見たら やっぱり悪があるんだ
アラがあるんだと じゃあどんな解毒剤でこれ消えるのかということこそが道徳なんです
だからずいぶん道徳的な定義が
道徳の定義が変わるんです
仏教では 要するに道徳とは自分個人が発見して守るものです
他人に言うものじゃない
能力がない人は 善人というのは智慧のある人に相談すればいいんです
例えば 自分で発見できないんだったら
まあブッダみたいに真理を知っている方のところに行って教えてくださいと
というと教えてくれます
それに自分で発見できます
道徳が神が決めるものでもAbsoluteでもありません
それは仏教の考え方なんです
心に現れる悪によるものです
心に悪があれば道徳もあります
道徳は相対論として成り立つんです
しかしまだないんです
自分でそれを育てないと
しかし 人間の心の普遍的な働きを発見すると
悪が現れる方程式を発見できる
それは後の講義で時間があったら説明します
この悪が現れる方程式があるんです
それもブッダにしか発見できません
ですから 時間があったら説明します
今日ではなくて この方程式から普遍的な道徳
非道徳を決められます
ということは 上の文章にちょっと違うんです
道徳はAbsolute
絶対的 変わらないものではないんです
悪が現れたら 相対的に善というものは出てくるだけの話で
しかし心にどのような方程式で悪が現れるのか
その原因何なのかということの方程式を発見すると
やっぱりこれこれこれという悪がありますよと
それにはこれこれという解毒剤があるんだよということが定めることができます
それは仏教で全部定めて終わっているんです
新しくするぐらいのものはないんです
はい 次に行きます それからブッダの言葉
ブッダは偽善をなくすという言葉
アッターナメーバパタマンパティルーペーニウェーセーアタンニャマヌーサーセイヤナキリッセイヤパンディタ
それ全部詩 歌ですよ まず自分自身が正しく戒める
他人にはそれからアドバイスをする
このように智慧の人はね
比肩は汚れません それで偽善ないでしょ
まず自分でやって 暇があったら他人にも言ってもいい
自分でやらないで言うと偽善だからね
ダンマパダの百五十八番目
アッターナンチェカタタカイラヤターンニャンアヌーサーサティ
スダントーワタダメータアッターヒキルドゥンダモー
他人に指導する通りに自分で行いなさい
他人に説教する通りに自分でやりなさい
よく自分を制御しなさい
自分こそが制御しがたいのです
だって みんな悪好きでしょうに
難しいんです
はい スッダサンワッジャンアンニサンアッタノパナドッダサンパレサンヒソワッジャニーオプナアティヤターブサンアッタノチャパナッチャーデーティカリンワキタワサ
トーよく聞いて
他人の過ちは見やすい
自分の過ちは発見しがたい
他人のその過ちを籾殻を風に流すように言いふらす
これは昔の話で 昔はこの籾を取って
この風が吹いてくると風に当たるんです
そうすると 本当の籾が下に落ちて
この殻はサーッと飛んでいくんですよ
そうやって我々は人の悪いところだったら平気で言いふらす
自分の悪いところは全然見えないんだよと
それから自分の過ちの場合は
賭けをする詐欺師が負けの駒を隠すように隠すのです
例えばカードでもトランプでも何でもいいんです
詐欺師がいて 詐欺をやって賭けやってやると
自分が負けを引いちゃうと
すぐそれ隠しちゃうんです
そんな感じで自分の過ちを隠すんです
だからお釈迦様はみんな犠牲になっている立場でいて
この犠牲にならないように
そういう風にはっきりと仰っているんです
はい パレワッジャアヌパッシスニッチャンブッジャアネサンニノアセワタッセワッダンティアラソアセワッキャ大体これで大体決まりですけど
他人の過ちばかりを考える
他人をいつも見くびる
そのような人が心の汚れを増やす一方です
汚れなくす道から程遠い
だから人間語ってる道徳っていうのはそんなもんで
道徳語れば語るほど心が汚れて汚れて汚れて
人殺すところまで発展するんですよ
戦争するところまで発展するんですよ
だから道徳は仏教でブッダの言葉でしかないんです
だから今 私はずっと何語ったかとも一応理解できると思います
だから我々は今までの道徳観
善人ぶりは かえって自分の心を汚して地獄に落ちる道なんです
これではもういい人間になれません
どんどん悪い人間になるんですよ
俗世間の考え方でいい人間になろうなろうとしたっても
ちょっと危険 お釈迦様言うのはもうあの人があれが悪い
この人のこれが悪いとか見くびると
悪くなるのは自分の心だよと
はい それで結論 いろんなところから選んだんですけど
今日からね ナパレサンビローマニナパレサンカタカタンアッテナールアヴェッケーアカタニアクタニチェ
これが覚えたっていいんで
すごいかっこいい偈です
ナパレサンビローマニナパレサンカタカタンアッテナールアヴェッケーアカタニアクタニチェ
他人の過ちはもう結構ですと
私にとっては そんなのはどうでもいい
結構 他人がしたことしなかったこともまた結構ですと
自分に対しては 自分自身を観察しなさい
何を行ったか 何を行っていないかと
だから自分がずっと個人で一人で
あの人やったことはそんなことはどうでもいい
結構 この人はやらなかったが
それも結構 しかし私は何やってるのか
私は何をやってないのかということだけ考えなさい
それで他人の過ちだけ発見することで
この世で語っている道徳の問題をこのように解決する
それでお釈迦様が世の中にあった道徳をそれで最終結論で解説
解説 解説しているんです
解決しているんです それより優れた教えはもう誰にも言えない
偽善も現れなくなる 世の中から偽善が消える
はい また一つのポイントで終わります
見せる道徳という この見せるですかね
みんなに見栄張りという漢字はわからない
モラリストは自分を知って欲しがる
認めてもらいたくなる
いい人だ 自分 あ あれ 徳を間違っています
ね 自分の徳を言い触らす
私はこういうものであると
他人に簡単に発見できるように宣言して道徳を守る
修行する まあ修行なんかに入る場合は派手に宣伝して修行に入ってくるんです
宣伝ばっかり 私はこういう
私はこれぐらい修行してるんだ
3ヶ月とか道場に行ったんだとかね
そうやって言いたくて言いたくて
たとえ良い人間でいても
その行動はエゴです  その中に真面目な人はいますよ
私は半年も道場に入りますよと言って
半年道場に入って真面目にやる場合もありますけど
結局はエゴ 自我です だから完成はしない
そういうケースなんかはもう嫌になるほど丸々知ってるんだからね
自我は悪の発祥地なのに
これがもうみんな忘れているんで宣言して
みんなに知って欲しがる
ただ単に自分が良い人間だとみんなに知ってもらいたいと思ったら
もう終わり それがエゴで道徳完成しないんですよ
なぜならばエゴが悪の発祥地なんです
微妙です はい それであるボラの修行者をお釈迦様はものすごく怒鳴ったんで
そのケースなんです 他人に認めてもらう気持ちをさておいて
自分の心を清らかにする目的で道徳を守るのが正しいのです
他人に認めてもらっても
他人に知ってもらっても
知らなくてもどうでもいいんですよ
ものすごい密かに内緒で心で良いことをして回らなくちゃいけない
おそらくイエス様も同じことを言ったと思います
左右手でやったことは左手には知らせるなよ
キンテージャターヒドゥンメーダーキンテーアジナサーティアアッバンタラガアッバンタラ
そうそう 言葉を忘れています
アッバンタランテーガハナン
アッバンタランテーガハナンバヒランパリマッジャシー
キンテージャターヒドゥンメーダーキンテーアジナサーティアアッバンタランテーガハナンバヒランパリマッジャシー
ある厳しい苦行をしている行者が
何かお釈迦様にチャレンジしたんですよ
あんたはね なんだ贅沢な服を着て
こんなのは修行でもなんでもないという感じで
それでその人はもうお風呂にも入らない
もう何もしない で 髪の毛を切らない
髪の毛はこうやって結んで上に結んでいるんです
すごい汚い まあそこでもうシラ
何でしたっけ シラミやらもう大体髪の毛を結んで洗ってないというと
この肉まで生えていくんですよ
中に 何年経つと だって体って生き物だから
植物だから 我々毎日あれやってるんだから
もう丸くて丸いですけど
もし長くして結んで そのまま置いておいちゃうと
肉まで生えて生えていくんです
[笑い]そういうことで
それからこのただこのなんとか鹿の何でしたっけ
私ももう辞書で引いて書いたんですけど
自分では読めない あの
え カモシカ？カモシカの皮を取って
ただそれそのままで着ているだけ
ですので 革製品で作ったあれを着ているわけじゃないんです
革製品のズボンとか革製品のジャケット
そうじゃなくて 革そのものを着ているんです
だからあなたのもつれた髪は何？あなたが着ているこのカモシカの皮は何？あなたの心はひどく汚れている
あなたは外だけ磨いているとお釈迦様は叱った
あんたはね 外だけかっこつけてるんだけど
心の中はものすごい臭いんだよ
お釈迦様は心の中 無色透明な純粋にすること
を教えているんです だから外はどうでもいいんです
しかし 仏教の人はだらしない格好ではいないんです
ちゃんと綺麗な服を着て
ちゃんと体を洗って 最近の方々だったらきちんと髪の毛を整理して散髪していなくちゃいけない
しっかり決まってスマートでいなくちゃいけない
僕たちはものすごい厳しい戒律の中でも
すごくみんなに嫌われないように
体を綺麗にして 衣を綺麗に洗って
綺麗に衣を着ていなくちゃいけない
もう私を例にしないでください
はい それで終わります
もれる人がいない世界は平和
ということで 道徳主義者はまだ火がついてない爆弾のようなものです
付き合いはするが どこかで心がビクビクしている
我々は道徳喋ってる人と仲良くするでしょ
でもどこかでちょっと引いちゃうでしょ
だって何言うかわからないんだから
ちょっと下手こいたら爆発するんだから
本来の道徳とは何かと理解した方が役に立つ
だからブッダが教えた本来の道徳は何なのかと分かった方がいいと思う
なぜなら 自分が守りたくないという気持ちをさておいても
非道徳は危険なものです
例えば 道徳が守りたくない気持ちは皆様にあるかもしれませんだけど
だからといって非道徳っていうのは困るでしょ
これは自分にも他人にも困りますから
勉強した方が良いということで
一応終了したいと思います
次いってみてください
終わりです  そういうことで
道徳主義について仏教的な考え方
次はまた もし異論やらね
反論とかございましたら
二 三分ぐらいで質問を出してみてください
これだけの量でもやっぱり五回ぐらい言わなきゃ足らないぐらい大変な内容なんですけど
とにかくビビビと 言ってしまったんで
見えてたのが 見えてたのがパリタイプさんに反対した
何何？ パリパリパリタイプと律法学者とかなんで反対する心が汚いとか言って
こう簡単に使った時があるんですけど
言ったことによっても道徳が潰れちゃうという
だからイエス様自分ってやってればよかったんだけど
それを人たちに向かって攻撃するみたいに言っちゃったことが道徳が潰れちゃう
うーん まあね イエス様はかなりすごい色んなところで失敗してるんですね
言葉を喋る場合はね だから同じことを厳しく
お釈迦様も他人に非難して
前出した偈でも ものすごく相手を非難しています
長い間厳しい修行やってる人に向かって
あのファリシェンというのはもう贅沢三昧でね
もう明らかですけど お釈迦様を非難したのはもう真面目に修行する苦行者なんですよ
お前何やってこれ？でも全然問題なかったんです
なぜかというと この真理語ってるんだから
もう反対できません だからイエス様の場合はもうほとんど仏教の話言ったと思いますけど
彼がね 突然向こうで現れて
でももうちょっと勉強してたらばね
仏教でもね ちょっとここら辺もそういうのと私もちょっと痛く感じるところ結構出ているものです
でも時々落ち着いて まあその人々はその自分たちでやってる行為で肩を立てるでしょうと
っていうところはもういいんですよ
それは後でわかるでしょうというところはね
それはいくらか仏教的なんですけど
いきなり勉強向かって侮辱したっても
だから自分も無反にするんだからね
聞く人はね 聞く人が完全たる道徳でしっかりしていないと
言えない イエス様はこの殺されることになったのもね
もしかするとイエス様の個人的な生き方は随分お粗末というか
そんな大胆なことではなかったと思いますね
だからあなたの言い方見たってもどうったことはないでしょうと
態度向こうは取るんです
そこは聖書だからね まあ悪口は言わないでしょうしね
イエス様の個人的な生き方ってのはほとんどわからないですよ
ブッダの場合は個人的に何やってるのかということははっきりしていますけどね
ブッダは調べなさいと
あるブラマンは半年間かな
ずっともうすきっきりでお釈迦様を調べたんです
監視したんです 微妙にでも不注意でも何か間違いあるのかと
だからその点ではブッダがもう完全たる人格で自分でやってから言ってるんだから
お釈迦様道徳を説く場合は必ずその態度を取るんですね
だから聖書では少々失敗っていうのはね
見えちゃう 大きな失敗はやっぱり捕まられて殺されたでしょうね
それ以外は失敗はないんだからね
それは教養学的に何とか
あんなのは論理的に成り立ちません
神が何も悪いことしてない人を殺さない限り許せないぞ
人間が そんなにも悪い人間かね
それは理屈じゃないんです
かわいそうでしょう 本当にいい人なのに
いい人が殺したところで
我々の罪が許してくれるというのは
何の理屈もないでしょうに
それより世の中から悪をなくしてくれるのはありがたいんですけど
枕高くて寝られるし イエス様殺さないでね
だからアメリカでもね
あの説教していたでしょ
殺された人は黒人の キンさんとかね
キンさんはそんなに失敗はしなかったんですけど
やっぱりそれでもやっぱりみんな嫌だからやっちゃうんですね
キンさんは黒人はものすごい気をつけて喋っていたんです
相手を侮辱しないで間違いだけ言っていたんです
それでもやられちゃったんです
そこでお釈迦様の例なんですけども
ある日お釈迦様は比丘たちにこう言ったんです
私は夜食べない だから昔からお釈迦様は夜召し上がらなかったんです
それで私はものすごい楽です
すごい楽で健康で 私はすごい体が健康的で楽で
もう別に太ることもなんともないしね
病気もなくいますよと
だから君たちもいかがでしょうかね
夜食べない方が健康的で楽で楽しいよと
夜はするの大変だからね
電気もない世界に 道もろくにないね
遠い昔 それで比丘たちは何のことなく文句言わずに
何も言わずに はい わかりました
で終わったんです そこである地方にもあるお坊さんがいたんです
その人はお釈迦様のことはわからない
でも比丘たちはお釈迦様に言われたら
それから全ての仏教徒がスッタタをを守らなくちゃいけない
ブッダは一応権威であって
絶対的な存在だから 信仰する人にとってブッダに逆らったらもう終わりだと
だって真理語ってるんだからね
逆らえないでしょう それでその地方にお坊さんにもお坊さん何人かが行って
君 知ってますかと お釈迦様は新しいことを教えてくれたんだと
夜食べないっていうことを教えてくれたんだと教えたんです
そうしたら このお坊さんが
私はね 朝も食べる 昼も食べる
夜も食べる で 間食もする
好きな時食べる 私は健康だよ
結構楽ですよ 言ってお釈迦様のあの道徳的なメッセージを捨てちゃったんです
それでお坊さんたちは何も反論できなくて
黙って帰ったんですけど
どうしようか困ったと
お釈迦さんに報告したら
お釈迦様はその比丘を呼んだんです
呼んで何のことなくこういうことを言うんです
あのね もし私が何かが悪いとはっきり知らない
なのにあなた方にこれは悪いという
もし私が何かが良いとはっきり知らない
経験していない 悟っていないにも関わらず
君たちにこれが良いと言うならば
これは指導者として教える人として不審ましい行為だとあなた思いますか？と
いわゆる偽善のことなんです
ただ その人は いや それは指導者としてふさわしくない
だから え？私はこれがあなた方に悪いと悟ってるんだから
知ってるんだから悪いと言うんだよと
これがあんた方には良いと私は知ってるんだから
悟ってるんだからあなた方には言ってるんだよ
ものすごい強烈なそのキータデッスッタという経典ですけど
えらく怖くなるんですよ
読んでみるとすっごい強烈な言葉
そこであなた知ってますか？私はすべての楽しみをやめなさいと言ってますかと
いえ そんなこと教えてないんだと
では 私はすべての苦しみを味わってくださいと言ってるんですか？と
いえ そんなことも言ってないんだと
では私は何を言うんですか？と
私はこういう風に言うんだよと
ある楽しみを楽しんじゃうと
あなた方の心は成長する
それだったら私はその楽しみを選んで
これはやってくださいと言う
ある楽しみを味わっちゃうと
君らの心が堕落する 私はその楽しみだけやめなさいと言う
ある苦しみを経験して苦行すると
君たちの心が堕落する
私はその苦行をやめなさいと言う
しかし ある苦しみを経験してみると
君たちは成長する その苦しみを味わいなさいと言う
ということで 延々と語るんで
だから 夜食べるってことに一言も触れなかったんです
勝手にする しかし そのお坊さんはそれっきりでもうやめるしかないんです
なぜかと お釈迦様は自分でまず守って
それはこの悟りに関係ないんですよ
食べるか食べないかということは
ただ 体の健康と七面倒くさいかったからだからね
托鉢 夜托鉢に行く時間で修行できるんだから
すごい単純な理由 だってその前お坊さんたち食べてたんだから
だいたいこの村なんかに住んでるお坊さんたちのことは親戚でしょうし
村人は だからもうだいたい自分が料理作った時は持ってきて
じゃあもう食べてくださいという状態で
三時であろうが六時であろうが
もらってきた時は 持ってきた時は食べたりする
それで悟らないということでもない
しかし 街なんかに住んでいる場合は托鉢行かなくちゃいけない
街でいたっても電灯は街灯あるわけじゃないんだから
大変時間かかって苦しい
だからもう普通なことなんですが
それでお釈迦様はしっかり自分でやってから結果をちゃんと実証してから言うんだから
これは守るしかないんです
反対はできない その件で一人のお坊さんが反対してみて
かなりひどい目に遭っただけ
だからお釈迦様の凄さと仏教は失敗しなかったところはそういうところにあるんです
仏教は広めないことがそちらになるんです
人間というのは道徳は嫌だから
そういうこと  先生 ちょっと関係ないことなんですけども
先生のお名前の意味  言うの？ 覚えにくいお名前申し訳ありませんから
それは覚えなくていいんですよ
それは村の名前で 名前はスマナサーラです
それは覚えやすいんです
半分覚えなくても 別に覚えなくても
名前はスマナサーラだけなんです
その名前はたくさんいるんだから
区別するために生まれた場所を使うんです
我々は家の名前は使わない
だからスマナっていうのは良い心ということで
サーラっていうのは結構充実してあるんだというありえないことを名前に書くんです
これはインドの文化なんです
名前の意味を聞いてあなたがどうですかというのは全く無縁
そこで我々冗談で言うんです
ダナパーラという名前の人がいるんですよ
ダナパーラというのは財産の支配下というか
王様みたいな意味なんです
でも 1円も 1円も 1文もないんだと
人から物を買うて生活するんだと
人生っていうのはそんなもんだと
名前と事実は ダナパーラは乞食をやると
ブーミパーラには住むところもないんだと
ブーミパーラっていうのは大地主という意味なんです
で わし名前スマナサーラですからね
それは一応発音が簡単
では私質問なければもう私は早めます
はい